this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Carl and yes Pam aren't we all
grateful for this guy he definitely out
kicked his coverage marrying Sally and
having these two wonderful boys a scary
time for Carl and thanks for everybody
for keeping us updated and man what a
story he's making the local news this is
quite a thing Pam have you seen him and
we FaceTime at least three times a week
we FaceTime FaceTime me when he first
got out he had to be in just to show me
his beard anything had helped this ugly
mug yeah he came back to work on Monday
oh gosh
of course he did because he has to go
back there he wants to go back to being
global turf he does yes yes he does he's
in he's doing really well he was on a
ventilator for 15 days and I told Carl
it's about hope yeah you just hope so
and we're so glad that you are giving us
play-by-play activities of your back
yard it looks like they were actively
reading the pool instructions while you
were lamenting the the trampoline
killing the grass and Brian wanker
confirmed that yes the trampoline will
in fact kill the grass and then Kobe
schmuck erupt you guys went all in on
the trampolines 5 hammocks 5 hammocks
hillbilly social distancing maintaining
a sense of humor Pam is really very
important during these times and and
really to help the grounds folks the
sports folks along these lines EST ma
has just done a spectacular job in
providing resources one of these that we
talked about last week is is one I'll
highlight there's a couple more that
we'll get to as we go on let's do a
quick recap of the weather before we get
out to a conversation about sports turf
management for those of us in the
Northeast you can see we remain well
behind normal now this is going to
change dramatically over the next week
but with the warp will come copious
amounts of rainfall for us in the north
our tea guy tano our climate specialist
at the Northeast Climate Center was
talking to us about a rain event that
proceeds a tropical storm and so that's
what we're going to be experiencing he's
not as worried about the tropical storm
but it could be large swaths of anywhere
from two to three to four inches
throughout the northeastern US so while
the temperatures will begin to warm and
we will start to see some change to this
they're really not going to be much more
than normal and so we'll remain behind
the amount of degree days will
accumulate base 50 degree days you know
indicating the amount of time above
average temperature is above 50 degrees
you will see some improvement but a not
not a huge dramatic shift there will be
some temperatures in the 80s expected
now if you started to plan your things
at the end of March and early April in
the Northeast you saw back in April that
soil temperatures were already creeping
into the low to mid 50s
a month later again it looked like it
was surging on it didn't hadn't moved
that much and and as of recently we
still aren't very much further ahead
we're slow to come along here now of
course where Pam is out in Ohio it's
much further ahead certainly down in
southern Ohio Scott to be a little bit
further ahead than we are up here but
you can see soil temperatures are really
not driving things now to me one of the
fascinating things about this is is that
there needs to be let me see that I get
this in the right place yeah I got this
in the right place there we go
Pam did a wonderful job with the team
there how state the Ohio sports turf
Managers Association right away out of
the gate because of course the growing
season is enhanced you know further
ahead than it is here right away you got
these top ten maintenance practices to
focus on particularly as we were
confronting maybe not being able to
access the field now more recently the
SP ma is of course responded to this and
a recent
publication came out healing through
sports I thought this was really good
sort of compiling things and our
colleague feminized colleague Grady
Miller at NC State was asked this
question because apparently there were
people in a sports turf world who all of
a sudden couldn't access their fields
now of course this is a bermudagrass
field but the question to Grady that Pam
is also a columnist in the sports turf
magazine answering questions as well the
question is what do I do if I can't get
there for months well you know I put
just a simple answer up here because
what bermudagrass yeah it's not great
it's probably going to take a few weeks
to get it back but if you get it at the
right time when bermudagrass
can can sort of rejuvenate and grow
after a scalping you're likely in good
stead but cool season turf abandoned to
some degree like this even sports fields
you see the fields starting to grow now
in the southern part of the state you
can see the infield skin beginning to
get weedy when you're not allowed access
to the field obviously recovering these
things are gonna take enormous amounts
of labour and care and of course one of
the things everybody's gonna tell you is
you know if your fields went into this
pretty good hopefully with just some
minimal maintenance they'll come out of
it pretty good and that's been pretty a
pretty consistent message that we've
seen but Pam you wrote this really great
article recently about thresholds for
acceptable we cover we talked about this
a little bit last week with sera Caen
but what I think this highlights to me
are a couple of tools I want to talk to
you about with regard to this idea of
you know going out looking at your
fields getting a sense of how they
perform and using tools to communicate
that to the people that we work with so
here's the SDM a Excel spreadsheets
playing condition index here is your
report card for rating athletic fields
you know trying to quantify sort of how
we
two things and here's our really simple
sports turf rating system that we have
on our sports turf site now I'm not
partial to any one of these I think you
know sitting down at a conference or
listening to this and saying okay well I
can see how to use this tool and really
I have to say Pam this is the question I
have for us to chat about today is is
live
I've been alarmed at the amount of
people that are struggling with just
being able to do essential maintenance
they're not able to add to justify even
accessing their fields so are you seeing
much of this and let's start there
are you seeing much field abandonment
people not realizing what they have to
do I'm seeing at all different levels so
I have a friend who manages a
professional baseball field and he
doesn't have any fungicide and there's
been a lock on buying anything so that's
his problem and then I have you know
local school district and local park and
rec facilities the grass is six eight
inches tall in field starting to get
weedy my local school districts have
noticed they have come out in a mode to
keep it to try and keep it somewhat
manageable but yeah I think there'll be
it's at all levels all levels and at all
different types of sports and is it
related does it have anything to do with
us not being able to talk to people
about what we need to do or is it they
just shut it down and they didn't want
to hear from anybody I think it's
probably the last the last mainly budget
freezes hiring freezes interns let go
those decisions were made very quickly
by administration without the input I
think from a lot of field managers so I
think I think with it just been an
unprecedented time those decisions were
made really quick and and as we begin to
reopen up do you see a role for going
out and assessing the field I mean some
people are gonna say listen we're not
playing sports where we got
we'll get to it in the fall how can we
you think these tools will be useful in
helping people communicate the things we
have to do up the line yeah I think we
have to I think we have to concentrate
on the on the the big three you know we
have to say look we've got a we've got
to do married we've got a mo we're going
to control weeds and then depending on
your situation it might be disease
control or insect control or irrigation
or fertilizer whatever it is for your
particular instance but I think you need
to rather than try and do everything
just concentrate on the one or two or
three of the basics and this has been
what you've developed to guide these
decisions now is it your sense that guys
have been able to do these things so
you're saying there's a range obviously
losing ground on Bermuda grass at this
time of the year might be able to be
made up what about the cool season guys
that are coming back to six-inch turf
well I think we're trying to get the
message across that you know mowing
mowing is a stress so because we know so
much we have to do that other things you
know irrigation fertilizer pest control
if we're not mowing we don't have it's
not under as much stress we can also
back off those other practices so I
think just just having a mowing plan and
being able to communicate that mowing
plan will be key you know it's the cool
season grass isn't going to die if it
gets to be eight inches tall you've just
got to have a really good plan to bring
it back to your original height so
whether that you know using rotary
mowers maybe even taking clippings off
so that you don't have you know tons of
clippings on the field house maybe work
with some volunteers try and help me
mowed more frequently because I don't
see unless we've got sports on these
fields I don't see the staff levels
coming back up and that's another issue
is manpower there just isn't the people
to do the mowing because then they've
cut seasonal staff yeah the seasonal
staff is where the loss is going to get
hit
as an aside I know you're active in the
scouts and I know that STM a did this
really nice thing with Scouts I know
that Nichole with the Orioles is doing
some sense temps up you know this is
happening to try to connect the youth to
this industry do you see this as a
really opportune time it seems like
you're you know you're doing it at home
with the kids you're doing it with the
Scouts is this a really opportune time
when our staffing levels are low to to
use that time to get people involved you
know communities have sports
associations is there a way to use them
to help get back and do things safely if
we don't have the staff what are you
what are you seeing about the connection
between this brewing enthusiasm around
this as an you know a stem area of study
and the potential for it to help us
moving forward I think it's been a
wake-up call for us all in academia that
our student levels are down in the
industry and we're trying to look all
different ways all innovative ways that
we can connect with youth whether it's
to Scouts or stem videos or going into
schools or go a event yeah 4-h I mean
it's all there I love what Nicole's
doing I've sent a lot of people doing
the same kinds of things they just don't
know we exist we just have to keep
getting the message out there that this
is an industry that exists and I'm
teaching a plant science merit badge to
a hundred Scouts right now across the
nation clock every night this week will
come on and we zoom and there's a
there's a section in the plant science
book about careers they have to they
have to look at plant science careers to
scrap turf grass isn't even mentioned
I'm shocked I'm shocked there's a plant
science merit badge it's such a you know
the fact I mean I years ago here at
Cornell we used to have to do marketing
just to teach kids what plant science
was that you could actually study plants
and never mind at the specialized level
we're at now that's a it seems so
obvious a lot of us work at schools
right it's been a wake up for academia
but but at the same time students in
high school
fools you know getting them involved
that at that age is going to help build
this later on but but we have to
reconcile that with as soon as times get
tight at various places unless you're at
the highest level it's a very different
industry there's only one per I mean how
many people at these facilities right
what's happening at the you what's
happened at the you where you are at the
Ohio State what's happening to the
sports fields they're um they're being
maintained still so Brian gimble and the
crew were staggering times coming in
they'd still be maintained and they've
synthetic and natural yeah we've got
synthetic in the stadium we put it in
there since 2007 I believe baseball
basketball synthetic and rugby synthetic
so there's a lot of synthetic turf all
infield yes yes and so he's not is he so
one of the things that happens is the
municipalities to school districts the
lower level things have fewer resources
but really that's where a lot of the
jobs are I feel like we're having a hard
time getting those people to value the
professionalism and I see in your report
card one of the questions you ask is do
you have a certified sports field
manager and I just think that isn't
prominent enough in our industry to
demonstrate the professionalism you need
to manage these fields at a high level I
agree and I think it comes down to the
type of people who are in the industry
are typically hard-working humble people
that don't like to you know talk to
their own horn whatever you want to say
but we've got to do it you've got to put
a suit on look smart talk to people you
know when we went to the Women's Forum
STM a years ago we we looked at the lady
who wrote there she was the CEO of
Facebook and we we were given a copy of
her book each and she says sit at the
table if you're invited to a meeting sit
at the table
and I keep telling sports to have
managers this if you're invited to them
that meeting you go in that room and you
sit at the table you don't sit on the
edge and keep quiet you have a voice you
know sit at the table that's that that's
the message have you found that these
field assessment tools help bridge that
gap
I worked solutely data is power
absolutely
data is power if you can go and you can
say look we've gone from 30% we'd cover
to 80% we'd cover this this during this
pandemic we have to do something with it
numbers tell the entire story dangerous
power and we talked about that last week
with sera Caen as weed populations
increase the traffic tolerance is not
going to be good now you know I know you
mentioned in your article about micro
clover right this is gonna be a buzz you
know people buzz I keep saying it it's a
funny pun but we don't want covert on
sports fields I think the issue with it
is the big issue and I was listening to
Paige Boyles webinar last night and I
know she's on tomorrow one of the
challenges where there is that you can't
control where the weeds if you've got
micro clover in you and you mix how do
we you know that needs addressing the
we're teller on Soviet the mowing
quality of it I think a 10% probably it
wouldn't you know what percentage is a
good percentage and how do we control of
the weeds those are some of the
challenges with it well and you know
clovers not one that plays nice it
starts out sort of interspersed and then
it gets clumpy and and one of the things
we've talked about consistently in these
webinars with chase and when everybody
else is you know when an athlete plants
their foot if one spot is markedly
different from another spot they're
either if they don't sense it there's a
higher likelihood for injury in those in
those situations so anything that gets
clumpy and weeds are one of those things
that maybe not might not be as obvious
could then lead to problems with safety
so let me transition to safety I've been
pounding on it we've had a number of
people talking about it but gosh Pam no
one's got a clay it seems like no one's
taking this data at the various levels
what do you think is one of the ways
we're going to be able to have some
success in getting these fields looked
at as an aspect of school or player
safety it will probably come through
some kind of legislation or being forced
to do it I think usually this it doesn't
it doesn't happen
we have to do it you know in Columbus
Public Schools we've got 17 high schools
and so that's a lot of schools to get
tested that's a lot of you know that's a
lot of equipment they just don't have
the money the only budget item they have
um that only line-item they have for
sports turf management at our district
he's mowing that's it nothing else just
knowing so how do we get the message
across and it's important I think he'll
come through legislation someone get
injured and it'll be something we have
to do to keep these safe has that led to
the preponderance of more synthetic turf
in your mind the idea that I need more
people in it somehow if I get synthetic
turf I don't have to you know quote its
no maintenance sort of thing and you
know I mean as professionals you know
I'm speaking as devil advocate but I
wonder if that's not the logic that they
use to get synthetic turf as well I just
need less guys absolutely they don't
have to worry about it we put it in we
don't have to stress about it where we
don't you don't need to maintain it it's
just gonna it's something we can we can
build and walk away from and everybody
can sleep at night that's that's their
that's the misconception and it wouldn't
so you know when you talk about 17 high
schools in Columbus Ohio and I know what
they feel about football and sports in
Columbus Ohio the fact that all they
budget for is mowing they must have a
fair amount of synthetic fields on those
on those campuses yes no they don't no
because they have to all be treated the
same so if they install one they have to
install sick people what what is the
well that's that you know and and every
time that's a huge capital expense and
that's been the argument for the you
know the long term investment you make
in a natural grass field now I'm an
advocate of having a synthetic field to
flex to when the weather's bad when when
you know the lacrosse team wants to get
out there and it's snowing particularly
in our neck of the woods I like it as a
flex field but not as a routine field
but if you put a lot of traffic on
sports turf even sand bass fields Pam
practice fields are gonna get worn out
yeah yeah they do I mean there's a
certain level of wear that you can put
on them but for me the balance is you
know as a sports to have person but also
as a parent I don't want my kid played
on something that's 150 degrees in June
July and August I don't I don't want my
kid breathing in whatever is coming up
those the chrome rubber and you know the
science is not the EPA is released
whatever they released and the science
isn't there but as a parent I have those
concerns and they get hard there there
is maintenance to them they're not
maintenance free and over the long haul
are they economic economically sound for
you know if my local high school puts it
in and it costs them over a million and
the only lasts eight years you know
they're good you need to start looking
at the numbers a little bit more than
they do I think well I think it's partly
because of what we're experiencing that
somehow natural grass has challenges
that are alleviated by getting the
synthetic turf and you bring up an
interesting point and you know you
wonder as the role you sit in both as a
parent and as a leader in the in the
sports turf world do how would you like
to be approached by sports turf managers
as a parent do you do you think even
parents notice the quality of some of
these fields their kids play on or just
like okay go play leave me alone I don't
think they notice it I don't think they
see it they don't notice it they don't I
mean I stand on the sidelines and I
grumble about quino fields my kids play
on it's 100 percent prostrate not weed
so by October it's completely brown and
they're playing on bare dirt to not wait
and brown not weed and it's just not a
consideration until I say something and
then they're like oh oh yeah like they
they don't see it alright Carl we got
some questions yeah there's a good one
from Brian here and it touches on a
couple things we've already talked about
he's actually a baseball coach high
school in Illinois and he said the
maintenance people who cut the fields
there are really more of a general
maintenance person he says they're
electricians out of mechanics by trade
and
coming out of the winter it looked like
they went from dad about seven inches of
Kentucky bluegrass and they just kind of
scalped it right down to an inch and a
half it was white and so now he's got a
situation where you know maybe it's just
coming back he's wondering what kind of
suggestions you guys would have and then
maybe another question is how should he
go about talking maybe to administration
or the maintenance people about the
importance of managing a turf field and
the stuff we talked about today be a
safety I'm gonna give that one to you
Pam I mean I think seven inches down to
three inches that grass lost a lot of
its leaf and what happened was the one
in a half well and what happens is when
you allow grass to grow it fins you get
fewer larger plants the plants just
respond difference in density goes down
in fact instead of going up as you lower
the mowing I density will go back up so
you're gonna see a lot of just thin turf
for a while and that of course is ripe
in Illinois for weeds I think I'll pass
at the fam about a talk about safety of
something like that and I've come across
this scenario before I work with a
volunteer group that would come in once
a week and mow it up an inch and a half
so it's you know it's not just about the
agronomy here it's how does how do you
relay that message in a kind way to the
ground staff you have to just educate
them in a kind way in an open way you
know just try and educate them on the
mowing height that it should be and how
we get there and the one third rule and
the fact that keep hammering that
message home that mowing is a stress
it's a stress and if we stress it too
much which they've done they need to
leave it alone don't Berta cut your
dairy don't spray anything just just
leave it alone
you may feed it a little maybe make sure
it's irrigated if you're going to a hot
dry period now in Illinois you'll be
we're getting really warm in Ohio now so
it's gonna be 80s I think by this
weekend if you've got an irrigation
system irrigated spoonful
leave it alone yeah especially because I
don't think oh we're playing baseball
maybe we're gonna start playing baseball
soon I haven't I know that I know Golf
is gearing up to get going but I haven't
heard anything beyond that is there
another question Carl before we start
wrapping up no more questions and maybe
I'll just ask one along those lines you
know Frank and I know you and I have
experienced this situations where the
coach and the managers in fields maybe
sometimes butt heads and we've kind of
discussed this on you know past webinars
but Pam are there any techniques that
you can give a turf manager to try and
defuse maybe those some of those
situations where a coach comes in and
you know maybe tries to tell them how to
manage the field and they feel
differently what's a good way to
approach that with with coaches and
managers chief managers it's an art form
unasyn seminars that you can go to about
this managing conflict while you've got
if you've got some time I'm only hands I
would recommend all sports Ted managers
look into you know leadership doing some
lead getting some leadership skills
managing conflict about listening you
know you listen more than you speak
my experience is those people don't know
what they don't know yeah yeah a lot of
times a coach will come in and and we
have talked about this and this is
really it was informative to me Pam we
were dealing with some soccer coaches
here and we tried to get feedback one
coach would be very detailed about the
kinds of aspects of the game that they
felt the turf was involved in and the
way the ball behaved and and was very
clear about well I don't like this I
want that so you know rolling and
watering and table you know the things
we know we can do to manipulate that
surface and then there was another coach
who said you know you got a moat lower
and and puts an topdressing and then
it'll be fine and so one guy was telling
me what they wanted and other guys
telling me what to do I have to sort of
I'm from New York everything sounds
sweeter when you say a Pam it doesn't
sound so sweet as hard as I try still
sound like what are you a dope so so so
I eat it's hard sometimes to deal with
these things and I think the most
important thing you said is you gotta
like okay this person just needs to be
massaged to understand there's many ways
to skin this cat and and not only it is
an art form to community it's an art
form to provide the conditions these
people want sometimes never mind field
hockey on natural grass I don't know how
much you run into that but that gets to
be enormous ly difficult because you've
got to cut the grass so low yeah yeah
most field hockey fields I see at the
REC level here in Ohio are all for annua
to those reason no it is an art form and
you've got to be the expert in the room
and data data data data everything you
say
backing up with data you'd be the expert
in the room but there's not you know
that's that's back to the safety day
yeah how many guys have data on their
hands on a pretty regular basis
maybe they got labor and or they have
their budgetary things right but but but
the assessment of those field ought to
be routine and I hear at even moderate
levels it's not yeah
not necessarily doing a condition survey
report like you'd have to do for a
building you know that simple data that
there are tools you can use we I just
listed three of them here you can make
one up on your own if it helps you
communicate what you're trying to do
because I think that's the way we're
gonna get these fields back when sports
return when they return yeah I agree I
agree and I used to take my students to
visit a field manager who I really
respect and he said also find out when
the money's coming from because if you
can find out their money's coming from
and you know how much you're bringing
into that pot you can get a little bit
of that money so it's not just about
agronomic data it's about you know find
out where the money's coming from find
out how much of that you contribute and
see if you can get a little as well so
we love to end on a grab and for the
money situation there Pam thank you so
much for taking the time to join us it's
so great to see you keep up the great
work with the scouts thank you very much
it is a pleasure to be here hey Carl how
about a survey Carl we got the survey
yep I sent that link in the chat box for
everybody one more time
and again thanks to Pam for hopping on
with us today just a reminder we're
gonna skip next week and then thanks
giving us the Ohi out here as a sign up
so we'll be back at the 28th next sports
check webinar thanks a lot Pam see you
guys thanks everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu